On 7th April, 2026,
Anthropic announced Claude Mythos
preview and project Glasswing.
Mythos, a general-purpose AI model, had
autonomously identified and exploited a
27-year-old
remote code execution vulnerability in
OpenBSD,
an operating system known primarily for
its security, granting root access from
anywhere on the internet without
authentication, without human
involvement after the initial
instruction.
The connected infrastructure on which
every financial system runs, browsers,
operating systems, software dependency
chains, can now be systemically scanned
and exploited at machine speed.
Every password, every login, every
payment credential can now be found and
used by AI automatically, faster than
any security team can respond.
The cybersecurity industry published its
emergency response 6 days later,
a quarter, 90 days, to adapt, they said.
Patch faster, spend more, the same
tools, the same approach, the same
vendors,
with more urgency and no doubt larger
invoices.
We knew that the web was the wrong
architecture for economic activity long
before Mythos.
That is why we built GRIDS, Gajumaru
remote instruction dispatch and
serialization,
a dead drop signature protocol that
removes the attack surface entirely.
The credentials are never on the
connected system. There is nothing to
find because the sensitive data was
never placed there.
I am going to show you this at work
right now.
Here we have Gaju Desk,
a built-from-scratch, zero-dependency
interface for the internet of economics,
installed on my desktop. You can see my
wallet,
my Gaju balance,
my account ID,
and the GRIDS URL field at the bottom.
That is how we authenticate and sign. No
username, no password, no websocket. It
operates from the device's secure
enclave. That means the private keys
never leave the signing context and
never touch the connected layer.
This is the highest level of
software-based security currently
available. Stage two of GRIDS will take
this further still, an air-gapped
dedicated hardware wallet with no
network connection of any kind.
But this is where we start, and it is
already a categorically better security
posture than anything else
in connected financial interfaces today.
Here is Gaju Mining.
This is a site we have built with GRIDS
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now.
I copy the GRIDS URL from the site
and paste it here.
Hitting okay,
I am then asked to confirm the messenger
signature request or the message
signature request.
I hit okay,
and you'll see I am now logged in.
Almost instantaneously, I am logged in
to the secure client portal and
dashboard.
No password, no credential transmitted.
Now I'm going to show you a transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the GRIDS URL. I paste it
into the GRIDS URL box, and I now get a
transaction signature request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay.
That's already done.
The transaction settled in under 3
seconds. You can see the transaction
hash. This is the proof-of-work
open-resource blockchain, Groot, that is
the base of the Gajumaru, making the
internet of economics possible,
1,846,200
times more transactionally efficient
than Bitcoin with 8.23 times greater
network security in commercial use.
Both the login and the transaction were
conducted using GRIDS. There was no
direct credential interaction on the
connected layer,
only the origination of the instruction
to the dead drop protocol, as you saw.
One more.
This is Gaju Market, the world's first
on-chain marketplace for goods and
services,
currently in testnet.
You will note that here we see a QR
code. This is how Gaju Mobile will
operate. You scan the QR code
and by the same mechanic, log in.
For now, I'm going to use the GRIDS URL.
Again,
log in here,
confirm here,
hit continue here,
and I am logged in.
Same mechanism, no password,
no database to breach.
Gaju Desk is in use now. Gaju Mobile
will deploy in May.
These applications are free to download,
install, and use. The solution they
offer can be implemented by any business
or government in the world within weeks,
well within the 90 days cybersecurity
industry estimates for action.
The protocol is open-sourced. The attack
surface that Mythos and any AI of its
capabilities can exploit is now gone if
you choose to make it so.
What you have just seen is GRIDS at
work. This is not future technology. It
is operational now.
Mainnet launches 26th April, 2026.
Thank you for your time.